كان أول
مشروع غير مسبوق بهذا
الحجم أكبر جزيرة من صنع الإنسان
تم بناؤها على الإطلاق
[موسيقى
] المياه الضحلة نسبيًا حول
الجزيرة
هي أحد العوامل الرئيسية التي جعلت هذا
المشروع
ممكنًا ، حيث أن أعمق نقطة 12 مترًا
فقط تبدأ من الصفر
منحدر لطيف للغاية في البر الرئيسي بطول 5000
متر حتى أعمق نقطة والتي هي
أساسًا حيث يقع أتلانتس الآن 12
مترًا
من الماء ، كان التحدي الرئيسي بالنسبة لي
والفريق والشركة هو
تسليم أكبر جزيرة من صنع الإنسان في
مدى ستة  سنوات
بهدف مضاعفة
طول الساحل الطبيعي لدبي
وقد فعلنا
ذلك المنظر في النخيل الذي افتتحناه
الشهر الماضي لذا فهو لا يزال جديدًا
جدًا وهو في النهاية أحدث أصولنا
التي تسمح للأشخاص بتجربة
ومشاهدة  البرلمان في كل مجده
بينما كان عليك قبل ذلك
القفز بالمظلات أو في طائرة هليكوبتر لتتمكن
من رؤيته على الرغم من أنني أمضيت سنوات
من البناء هذا المنظر المفتوح
360 مع كل  andmark على البر الرئيسي
والنظر إلى الجزيرة بالكامل.